lens avoue je nous sommes ce soir au big
band café à hérouville saint clair avec
tout d'abord paul langeois qui va nous
révéler deux noms du beauregard 2017
vous avez l'enveloppent je peux regarder
on a l'impression d'une 30 cérémonie
je vais découvrir les noms ah oui alors
ah oui quand même en petites dont
jacques jacques cftc qui au long on peut
savoir
oui eh bien écoutez on ouvre le vendredi
avec placebo qui fêtera ses 20 ans
la sortie de leur premier album et qui
nous fera un best-of pendant 90 minutes
et puis le deuxième nom du samedi qui
sera phoenix avec le grand retour de ce
groupe qui qui devrait arriver avec un
nouvel album en mars
retour au big band café d'hérouville
pour vos périodes de without qui seront
en concert demain soir 18 heures tandis
il concert gratuit avec romane avec
isabelle avec sylvain dans la lumière
d'habitude dans l'ombre avec daniel avec
patrick et avec laurent voilà et encore
vous n'avez pas l'effectif au complet
alors cette musique on l'a beaucoup
développée dans là où ça bouge en état
les dents dans les studios pour voir
comment ça sans registre et on se
demandait comment vous allez pouvoir
autres retranscrire cette énergie du
disque sur scène
[Musique]
au départ je crois qui s'était un peu
perdu dans les répétitions se disant que
le live c'était totalement différent du
disque et après ils sont venus un peu
plus vers un peu ce qui avait été fait
sur la gueule
[Musique]
l'électro rock moderne sensationnel va
nous c'est nous qui convient on adore
mais c'est vrai que c'est un mélange un
peu de notre culture à la fois actuelle
est à la fois passé parce que on a passé
la trentaine donc on a écouté un petit
peu de musique et c'est vrai que les
plus folles deux ans influencé c'est une
pierre angulaire un petit peu à tous
même romane qui est le petit gamin de la
bande
quelques 22 ans qui écoute les pink
floyd ou deep purple
[Musique]
jouer
monsieur des lettres habitat without
même si je voyais des gens qui ont l'âge
de mes parents ça s'est très bien passé
on avait le temps studio travaille et de
refaire de retravailler là il faut qu'on
soit sûr sur quelque chose du moment est
le plus le plus énergique possible nos
rangs la guitare donc on a parlé de
benfeld vous seriez le david guillemot
oui oui oui je suis sa réincarnation par
procuration savoir que le jour où il
meurt c'est moi qui prend sa place
c'est pas complètement votre univers non
c'est moi je suis plus dans la musique
latine mais je reviens à mes amours du
début parce que moi j'ai commencé par le
rock
[Musique]
on quitte le big band café à hérouville
pour retrouver mathieu bellingen qui est
lui à l'espace jean vilar et c'est du
brut ces brutes la terre de la terre qui
prend vie de la matière brute qui sert à
raconter des histoires sont encore en
train de rectifier certains le tire un
peu sur certains fait un petit moment du
spectacle en fonction comment le public
réagit qu'à ya tout ce travail
interactif qui se passe au tout début de
la création dans l'ombre
marie et odile façonne et interprète
tous les personnages d'une famille dit
qu'est ce que tu fais un port dans ton
lit jk fier c'est une compagnie que nous
avions déjà accueilli de nombreuses
reprises
je connais leur leur fit days analyse la
finesse de leur regard leur sensibilité
c'est toujours des choses très très fine
et
et mine de rien et quand elle m'en
parlait de de ce projet je me suis dit
bon coup ou diva quoi est elle comme al
salam empâté leurs signaux agile elle
pétrissent l'argile et c'est l'histoire
de l'apprentissage de la vie qui prend
forme
le spectacle a été créé grâce notamment
à l'espace jean vilar brut
c'est ce soir et demain à 19h30 à vif
tu penses vraiment oui gold et sacre de
son deux pièces dansées pour cinq
danseurs imaginé par le chorégraphe
israélien emanuel gat
il vient pour la première fois quand à
voir ce soir et demain au théâtre de
caen
[Musique]